talk about democracy dying in darkness
over the summer we warned you about the
biden administration releasing thousands
of migrants throughout the country in
the dead of night now newly uncovered
video shows federal contractors
discussing the secret flights warning
that the whole operation needs to be
kept under wraps and then explicitly
saying they don't want to alert the
media that's us
you don't want to be somewhere where
the spotlight
lot of this is just
no i i get it i just like stuff that we
don't
tell people because what we don't
want to do is attract attention we don't
want the media yeah like we don't even
know where we're going when they tell us
and those same contractors not mincing
words about who's to blame for the
secret flights
i get the whole
secrecy and all this [ __ ]
but this is even about my big yeah
you know what i mean
and why
you know why you know what yeah i know
but why
yeah come on no but what's what's the
big secret everybody knows what's
happening
the government's training america
ah filthy language reminds me of you
dana
jesse here's another instance where we
uh if we point out that there is a
crisis
it is dismissed because the media is
always going to dismiss anything that
comes out of our mouths right but we
knew this was happening we saw this
happening it sounded idiotic it's like
how could this happen
there it is not only if we pointed out
they'll dismiss it they'll call us
racist for pointing it out right yeah so
he's now taking
unvaxxed unvetted people he's flying
them to new york where now they can vote
in local elections they can go to
college on my dime
right they can work cash drive down
wages and then they can hold up a liquor
store with a gun
and then they'll only be charged with a
misdemeanor and then they can't be
deported because it's a sanctuary
situation
that's where we are right now and the
media will not report that right if you
had said this is happening 10 years ago
no one would have ever believed it but
that's where we are we have a hyde
amendment which says taxpayer money
can't go to fund abortions why don't we
have an amendment so taxpayer money
can't fund human smuggling because this
is a democrat human smuggling operation
i don't see any other way to look at it
is there an alliance between joe biden
and the cartels well they asked the same
question about trump and russia and
there was no evidence well now there's a
lot of evidence that they're working
together this is foreign people into the
country for why why would they do that
if it's for voting then it's foreign
interference in our own elections that's
correct this is an attack on democracy
exactly i i'm just asking questions
maybe
insurrection
let's tell joe biden he's president of
ukraine maybe then he'll defend the
quarter
do you know the particulars of this
stuff like where are yes the migrants
going like when they they land where do
they go okay i heard about this last
spring in westchester county they were
dropping them off at the westchester
county airport and i heard from some of
the police there and i just spoke to
another one of my sources who said this
has been going on since april all the
way through november most of them are
adult males single they have a few kids
the buses show up and they take them to
all over new york state to long island
they follow these buses to connecticut
to new jersey to other states in
addition what do they drop them off
though halfway houses will they drop
them off in costco in port chester okay
okay in westchester county and then they
drop them off to other people who end up
picking them up these kids are now in
schools all over the country schools now
have to hire new teachers taking away
time from american kids but here here is
the question what is joe biden trying to
accomplish why is he doing this under uh
you know at night why is he doing this
to us why is he allowing people with
criminal records and then saying well
i've analyzed these records and it's
only assault drunk driving drug offenses
so i want these people vetted i want to
know who's a pedophile who's a drug
dealer who drives drunk who beats his
wife who thinks it's okay to have sex
with his kid i want to know who these
people are but you know what the
democrats don't believe in law and order
so here is a perfect example of what
they're doing to destroy this country
so geraldo if this is a was a good plan
why
if there's nothing wrong with this why
is it being done at night why are the
non-transparent well i don't i think
there's something deeply wrong with it i
think that the lack of
transparency is is very substantive and
i think what it shows is the absolute
dysfunction
in the department of homeland security
to answer your question where do they go
generally speaking they go to sponsor
families they're not just dropped at uh
in front of markets to do when you look
you never see uh these mexican guys and
the hondurans as the homeless people in
america right they're not you're right
what you do is you you see them uh the
dot washing the dishes crop picking the
the crops the meat packing the pork
processing the lawn mowing the
babysitting you know it's uh
it i know it's outrageous this is what
it is
we just all we want is a process we want
law enforcement i agree with you i love
harvard
here the problem is that when they do
something like this it leads to the
monsterization the demonization of this
population and i think it's unfortunate
i just want to say one thing very
quickly there's more than a million
mexican
descendants
here undocumented illegally in the new
york metropolitan area more than a
million you never hear about them when
it comes to crime you never do why is it
they're riding the bicycles they're
living the pizzas the you know they're
in the diner washing the dishes they're
very industrious they're they're you
know
i i just wish the department of homeland
security would be honest
let the world know what the hell is
going on finish the the damn border wall
get some order
so this population is not continually uh
you know uh
demonizes it it's it's the uh you know
we new yorkers benefit from this while
all the border states are getting
screwed so it's like we sit from so far
away dana going hey i do i guarantee a
lot of my meals are being delivered by
illegal aliens it's easy it's fast but
i'm not at a border state who has to
deal with all of this chaos and also
like for and the schools and the
hospitals um in particular
one thing that's really interesting but
you're saying geraldo is especially for
me i i could be for some pretty strong
immigration reforms um and allowing more
legal immigration the country but what
president biden has done he's made that
conversation so much harder he has
because you have to have this
conversation first right i mean we all
knew that this was sort of happened you
heard about it but when you see the
video video really does focus the mind
on all sorts of things and we've seen
that play out over and over again um the
other thing that happened today the
administration said that they will never
looks like they will never release a
report about the migrants who were
whipped um by their horsepower
at border patrol
and again so again a lack of
transparency a lack of a willingness to
say we were wrong yeah and again it just
exacerbates the distrust and there's a
ton of distrust between the border
patrol
workers the agents and everybody that
supports them and this administration we
saw that with uh secretary mallorca was
in yuma arizona yesterday and one of the
guys there just turned his back on him
yeah you can see though why they're
being non-transparent the most
transparent event of biden's presidency
was afghanistan and we saw that they
don't want us to see how incompetent and
chaotic they really are they do it late
at night
and they insult us by thinking we're too
dumb to find out was it the new york
post that found out yeah and then if
they release the report that says the
border agents on the horses are clean
then the far left kooks are going to go
crazy yeah so they have to just kill it
because they have to kill it yeah hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else